hi anderson hi pitt how you doing
good honey how are you doing i'm all
right brad triggered a nationwide freak
out
reuniting with ex-wife jennifer aniston
in september during their
fast times at ridgemont high charity
table read
hi brad you know how cute i always
thought you were
i think you're so sexy jen played brad's
fast times fantasy
reenacting this famous dream sequence
will you come to me
the famous x's flirted laughed and joked
their way through the virtual event
wait just a minute oh god i'm so sorry i
did not know anyone who was in here cast
member julia roberts
was all of us watching along and loving
every minute doesn't anybody
knock anymore viewers were thrilled
one tweeted brad pitt and jennifer
aniston are single-handedly saving 2020
for me
back in may he also unleashed a
graduation surprise
brad here from quarantine with a shout
out to the graduating class
missouri state university yeah
green shirt here layered long and even
flipped up at the ends
brad gave this shout out to the college
in his hometown of springfield missouri
you made it enjoy congrats again
and think big but this isn't the first
time brad popped up
out of the blue good evening i'm dr
anthony fauci
first i'd like to thank all the older
women in america who have
sent me supportive inspiring and
sometimes graphic emails
it was week six of the quarantine and
brad's emmy nominated appearance on snl
as dr fauci
provided just the medicine we all needed
e.t first learned about the top secret
cameo
two hours before it aired i know i
shouldn't be touching my face but
brad shot the segment here inside his
hollywood hills home
a source told us that a small crew
dropped off the tv equipment
and set it up the wig wardrobe and
glasses
all came from snl and the oscar winner
used a teleprompter to do the sketch
created by the show's riders now there's
been a lot of misinformation out there
about
the virus snl reached out to brad's
theme after
this which actor would you want to play
you
oh brad pitt of course as the sketch
drew to a close
brad lost the wig and glasses and spoke
from the heart
we all kind of just felt things will
turn out all right
and to the real dr fauci thank you for
your calm
and your clarity and this unnerving time
and now
live kinda from all across america
it's saturday night brad's appearances
have been really getting us through
these tough times
we should do a check on the weather brad
how is it looking out there
looks uh pretty good we love this
unexpected
cameo doing the weather on john
krasinski's some good news
and we shed a few tears when brad teamed
up with the property brothers
to surprise a special woman in his life
gene's a dear old friend
there's people in your life that fate
brings together and i'm forever grateful
i want to keep
this goal love her with all my heart
that would be his makeup artist gene
she's been with the oscar winner since
his days in fight club
mr and mrs smith and once upon a time in
hollywood
she has seen it all there was a time on
legend of the fall she had to make up
my butt because of bad tan lines and
it's something when it comes up we can't
really look each other in the eye
all we had is dead and as if we needed
any more reason to love them
brad also has a giant heart he knew
this very special detail would mean the
world to gene
her father passed when she was very
young and then her mother when she was a
young lady and they were very very
very tight
that's gonna get her i'm the guy who's
gonna who's gonna cry on television
i should i this i i can't even tell you
i don't even know yet i can't take it
all in just here
um what it will mean to her
oh there's my mom and dad
oh wow it was really sweet seeing him
try to fight through those emotions of
oh boy i didn't know i was going to get
this emotional about this process
he couldn't hold it back and all i
thought in the back of my mind was
i made brad pitt cry for you to just
think of it it's really
well my main goal was just to get you on
television in november
pitt was spotted handing out groceries
to la families in need
that didn't surprise us because in 2007
only e.t
joined him in new orleans as he helped
build homes for victims
of hurricane katrina we were people who
are very fortunate and
if we can share a little that i think
it's um
there's no greater gift